[Music]
[Rainfall and thunder]
Hey it's me, Destin.
So I'm gonna explain why thunder
sounds the way it does.
And uh, we're in the middle of a
thunderstorm here, obviously,
so I'm going to try to make this quick.
So basically, if you're
standing on the ground here,
and let's say there's lightning
that happens way up in the sky,
really far away from you.
So what happens is, as soon as
it breaks the sound barrier,
that sound wave starts
traveling towards your body.
But also, the speed of the
electricity of the lightning bolt
is a lot faster than sound, so that...
Oh wow, that's going to be a big one.
At least I could see it.
So also, that lightning bolt...
[Thunder]
outruns the sound.
So the sound is simultaneously initiated
from all points along the
lightning bolt, at the same time.
So what happens is you get some cracks
that happen before other cracks
and you get this low rumble.
So you might get...
[Thunder]
a really low rumble, like that.
So what happens is, if the lightning bolt
is really really really far away from you,
then all the sound might make
it to you at the same time.
But sometimes you get this
long drawn out thunder rumble,
and that's because the sound is
coming to you at different points
from along the bolt.
It has to do with the distance
of the lightning bolt,
your position and the sound.
So there you go.
I know that's not in-depth at all, but
I'm in the middle of a thunderstorm.
But I hope you're smarter every day and
you at least get to think about it.
Have a good one.
[Thunder]
[Music]
...Good at this, so...
I'll show you. Watch his
head stay totally stationary
as I move his body. I can move his
body in pretty much any direction.
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.